part of the reason Marvel movies worked
so well is that their visual effects are
so seamless that we can rarely tell the
difference between the parts of a scene
that are real and those that have been
digitally enhanced but looking at the
behind the scenes action for each movie
it becomes clear just how definitely the
MCU might look if not for the talented
artists who turn each shot into stunning
and impossible action fair here's a look
at how some of your favorite Marvel
movies would have looked without the
magic of special effects Iron Man the
hero that started it all as Tony Stark
our favorite genius billionaire slacker
who turned himself into the title hero
by way of some supreme gadget Ori Robert
Downey jr. might have been seen as a
risky choice for a leading man spot but
he slipped into the role of Iron Man
like he'd been playing it all his life
but even though it was down he swaggered
has sustained his performance the
character would have been nothing but
great jumpsuits and green-screen
if it weren't for a team of VFX artists
from Industrial Light & Magic director
Jon Favreau wasn't a fan of CGI and
tried to build physical suits whenever
possible but an enhancement and
technology allowed for those
computer-generated versions to look
incredibly realistic ultimately he met
his goal perfectly you mix up the visual
effects with practical effects in a way
where you start to forget where one
begins in the other end Captain America
the First Avenger v MCU entry much Chris
Evans debut as Steve Rogers a scrawny
New Yorker who becomes an all-american
super soldier after agreeing to take
part in a military experiment Evans got
jacked for the role though his bulky
frame men that filming the scenes that
took place before he becomes Captain
America were very tricky the visual
effects departments were able to shrink
Evans actual body for some shots but
they also used a body double actor Lee
under DNA in the goal was to make the
audience fall in love with the character
before he gets any muscles before he
puts on a costume before he holds his
shield visual effects supervisor at some
Williams of Lola visual effects took
charge of putting Evans face on Lee and
his body and although his double was
diligent about mimicking Evans body
language as best he could the company
still had their work cut out Williams
told the wrap the head replacements were
tricky because you were taking the head
of a rhinoceros and putting on the body
of a gazelle and while the end result
wasn't perfect it sir
we work to showcase the cups epic
transformation Captain America the
Winter Soldier but though there were a
ton of aerial shots to grapple with in
the Winter Soldier the main challenge
for Lola visual effects was making caps
sweet our Peggy Carter and old lady
elderly look-alikes were brought in and
prosthetic makeup was tested though the
results weren't quite what they were
looking for so they improvised by
digitally projecting the skin of an
elderly actress directly onto Hayley
Atwell face Williams took still frames
of the elder woman's skin and added them
to the original photography of Hayley
Atwell in the role and the results were
spectacular guardians of the galaxy the
VFX team behind Marvel's the stoic space
opera guardians of the galaxy received
Oscar nominations for their hard work
which most notably included the creation
of two fully computer generated
characters and Rocket Raccoon and gross
while Rocket was voiced by Bradley
Cooper the actor did not do any of the
motion capture that job instead went to
director James Gunn's brother Sean Gunn
explained that he used her sibling onset
because he was able to work in the
conditions that most actors would
struggle with combining his limber
maneuvers with the digital prowess of
the VFX team the two carrots has not
only worked but won the hearts of just
about every Marvel fan Avengers age of
Ultron to create a compelling villain
for the second Avengers film James
Spader was zipped into a motion capture
suit and given the freedom to breathe
some life into Ultron the marauding
robot in the Avengers second through
pelting spada's performance for so
compelling that it inspired the VFX team
to make tweaks to their design
Industrial Light and Magic spend snow
told art of the effects the main
challenge was getting the subtleties and
the character of James Spader's onset
Ultron performance unto a character
whose face embody a made up of rigid
pieces of metal the face alone had 600
notes of ragging the fact that the robot
turned out to be one of the most nuanced
characters of the whole movie
meant that orders effort was not in vain
ant-man
surprisingly ant-man didn't rely on CGI
quite as much as some other Marvel
movies but with over 1600 visual effects
shots it was still a huge undertaking
the trickiest part wasn't creating
photo-real macroscale landscapes for
Scott Lang to scurry around on a calling
to visual effects supervisor Jake
Morrison it was a split second
she shrinks that cause the most headache
for the behind-the-scenes artists
director Peyton Reed watched films like
The Incredible Shrinking man and Honey I
Shrunk the Kids for inspiration in the
hopes of creating a definitive shrinking
movie he was more than happy with the
results Doctor Strange French Canadian
VFX artist a Stefan Sara T received his
second Oscar nomination for the
mind-blowing effects in Doctor Strange
which marked Benedict Cumberbatch's
debut with the title mage Sara T turned
to Christopher Nolan's blockbuster
inception for guidance but was also
inspired by the work of graphic artist
MC Escher and the psychedelic strange
tales comics from Steve Ditko's time at
Marvel approximately 1450 visual effects
shots had to be rendered over six months
Sara T said the biggest challenge was to
bring magic to the Marvel Cinematic
Universe in a fresh and innovative way
Sara T must have enjoyed the challenge
because he went on to supervise official
effects for ant-man and the wasp Thor
Ragnarok the third Thor instalment
surpassed box office expectations and
arrived as a funny and fan favorite
installment in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe like many of its predecessors
though the film featured an overwhelming
amount of digital superhero action
according to VFX supervisor Jake
Morrison there were almost 2700
digitally enhanced shots in the movie he
told arts of the effects I believe about
98% of the film passed through the
visual effects departments hands from
called the rock man allow me to
introduce myself my name is coke I'm
kind of like the leader in here to the
hogs championship bouts of Thor's
lightning power
Wow Wow I didn't hear any thunder but
out of your fingers was that like
sparkles the computer-generated images
were intense but the movie was all the
better for it in the end thanks for
watching click the loop icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love today
[Applause]